season high 49 points what was it like  going back and forth with kevin durant  there knowing he can put him  and pour on the baskets as often as he  wants  i was not going back to kd you know  katie is one of the greatest scorers to  ever play the game  you cannot play that way you know if you  go back and forth with a guy like that  he's going to score 50 70.  you know you know i'm saying i just had  it like a night and uh  at the end of the day i was able to slow  down and get to my spot  kept being aggressive uh but this this  game don't mean enough  it doesn't mean nothing to me um we  played them again  in two days and uh as you said it's a  team that we don't see in the  in the playoffs if you want to go to the  finals uh  but we gotta like in we've gotta come  ready on  whenever we play them and hopefully we  can get them in then